I think you said earlier the
documentaries are kind of this is their
their time right now what do you think
now so I think because the with the
streaming that's happening they're able
to get out there to a bigger audience
and there's also this notion of a doc
series that's been popping up and very
popular now where you can tell longer
form things that they stretch you're
like HBO's doing things that stretch
over a few nights
I know Netflix and other streamers are
doing things they're calling Doc's
series where it's like four to six
episodes of certain subjects but I do
think that reality these days is
somewhat more interesting than what
fiction can even dream up I mean there's
so many cool things happening in the
world that you kind of have to put a
magnifying glass on it and really
examine it and to me we're living in
such an amazing time where there's all
these compelling things every day and
you know there's there's a certain thing
that you don't want to really chase a
headline because it'll be irrelevant
tomorrow but if you look at certain
things that are hit upon sometimes like
the Carlyle Hotel where you continue to
see stories happen there you continue to
see history unfold those are the kind of
things you want to grasp onto so you to
me they're not irrelevant for historical
reasons but they're constantly current
so that's why I feel like film like this
something something will happen with the
streamers and how accessible it will be
to everyone eventually
besides the pockets that the theaters
are appealing to audience wise because I
just feel like it's always going to be
in the news in a sense they're always
gonna be something that occurs there and
that's just the magic of the place so
that's why I feel like a film like this
will appeal and be popular
similar with Bergdorf's that happened I
think there is a this this fashion
hunger out there people just can't get
enough of it and when that film came out
in 2013 I think it was at the height I
feel like it's fallen off a little bit
but and people are kind of getting over
saturated with it
but I don't know Docs to me I mean it
they're selling so I know there's a
marketplace for them and they're selling
at a decent enough level where you can
continue making them and I think that's
exciting for any filmmaker to continue
just telling your story and you know if
you have bidders on your content you
can't be in a better spot because you
continue to do what you do so I feel
like that golden period is you know you
don't you never know you can't really
recognize it when it's happening but I
think when we look back on this decade
for I would say from 2010 to probably
2020 we'll be like wow that was an
amazing moment where we were telling
amazing stories plus we came out of
worse a recession or supposedly we've
come out of one during that time and so
it's a relatively inexpensive way to get
a film made if you're doing it in
piecemeal it definitely is and you know
what's so interesting about the
recession is so the Big Short comes out
and it kind of examines what happened
there and I love filmmaking like that -
it's like the biopics and the studies
the journalistic studies of things like
all the President's Men and spotlight
like those to me are if you do them
right they feel like a documentary
almost so I feel like we're in that mode
of storytelling right now more than ever
where even Hollywood is on to the notion
of let's tell real stories
let's tell what what's happening but the
balance is of course that you're in the
Marvel world you know like there's
there's a I feel like the indie scene
and the ones that are the more renegade
pictures are the ones telling those real
stories but they're balanced well with
this whole Marvel Universe in Star Wars
where it's this imaginative fiction and
sci-fi etc where we're really getting a
great blend and I feel like you know as
I said when we look back on it will be
like wow that was a really great moment
a lot of people but Mon the 70s are over
and that storytelling is not happening
anymore or you know they I think it was
66 to 76 people look at and the 80s had
all those comedies right
but I don't know I feel like right now
we're having a really great moment and
we'll look back on it and say wow that
was that was terrific to be a part of
you